cuál es la situación de los bosques
puntualmente en américa latina'
hola buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación y bueno traer este tema tan
importante la verdad es que tenemos muy
poco es celebrar en el día de hoy pero
mucha área destruida para restaurar la
crisis climática hoy ya no se puede
hablar de cambios climáticos pero sí de
crisis climática que afectan todos los
ciudadanos pues en la amazonía es es la
última la última frontera para salvar no
este esta situación porque si la
destruimos ya no habrá ciclos naturales
del agua y américa latina tiene un
grande desafío en este sentido
básicamente en los últimos años
principalmente en brasil vemos una una
un aumento muy grande en la
deforestación y fuegos también
justamente le pregunto por lo que usted
está mencionando porque la amazonía
brasileña pues es el mayor bosque
tropical del planeta y hay un aumento sí
en la deforestación y consecuentemente
en estos incendios desde que el
presidente bolsonaro asumió la
presidencia en 2019 pero ahora joe biden
le pide trabajar en conjunto por el
medio ambiente como pueden cooperar
ambas naciones bajo un liderazgo como el
de bolsonaro
sí bueno lo que se puede decir es que si
hay un cambio de orientación hacia el
medio ambiente en brasil pero la
cuestión principal es que sabemos cómo
frenar la deforestación e hicimos esto
en el pasado y podemos hacerlo otra vez
no no es nada nuevo sólo que tenemos que
tomar medidas urgentes no y es una
oportunidad de colaboración con otros
países como dije tenemos que colaborar
porque es una cuestión global no local
así que cualquier intención de ayuda a
la avenida de donde sea es muy
bienvenida y lo que se puede hacer ahora
es manejar los temas de parar
evidentemente va a diferir sesión
tercero ese es el objetivo